sin ningún responsable por su muerte la
familia de sharina boatlé y la cadena
jazzira para la que trabajaba la
periodista han decidido dar un paso
adelante llevar su caso ante la Corte
Penal Internacional para sostener su
tesis que sharin fue asesinada por las
fuerzas israelíes
mi familia sigue sin saber quién disparó
esa bala mortal Y quién participó en la
cadena de Mando que permitió que mataran
a mi tía
fue asesinada a disparos mientras cubría
una redada del ejército israelí en yin
en la cisjordania ocupada el 11 de mayo
en septiembre Israel reconoció que
probablemente fue un error de alguno de
sus soldados pero se negó a perseguir al
culpable ahora los abogados del yasira
aseguran tener nuevas pruebas de la
autoría y del carácter intencional del
crimen las imágenes de vídeo demuestran
claramente que las fuerzas de defensas
israelí dispararon directamente contra
sharin y sus compañeros
todo el mundo puede presentar casos ante
la cpi y es el tribunal quien decide si
tomarlos o no una investigación a la que
Estados Unidos socio histórico de Israel
se ha opuesto
[Música]
en 2021 la cpi Ya abrió un caso por
crímenes de guerra en el conflicto
palestino israelí algo que da Esperanza
a los familiares para que el caso siga y
se consiga justicia para